[تصفيق]
يرتدون فراء دب بني مخيف وينزلون الى
الشوارع ثم يؤدون رقصه غريبه لطرد الارواح
الشريره من مدينتهم انهم راقصون الدببه في
رومانيا
[موسيقى]
هنا في مدينه راكوفا شرق رومانيا يخرج
المئات من الرومانيين ويقطعون عشرات
الاميال مع بدايه كل عام لاحياء مهرجان
الدب في تقليد متوارث منذ مئات السنين
هؤلاء يرتدون زيا تنكريا صنع منفراء دببه
حقيقيه ثم يتجمعون في مجموعات كبيره
ويؤدون طقوسا غريبه تتضمن الرقص والصراخ
واقرع الطبول ايمانا منهم بان هذا التقليد
يجلب الازدهار ويطرد الارواح الشريره من
المدينه
[موسيقى]
يختار سكان المدينه حيوان الدب بسبب
قدسيته لديهم ويعتقد ان تقليد رقص الدببه
نشاء منذ عده قرون حيث كان الغجر في
رومانيا ياتون بدببه حقيقيه ويدربونها
ويجعلونها ترقص على صفائح معدنيه ساخنه
لكن المهرجان تم ايقافه وحضر رقص الدببه
في عام
1998 وتم شراء اخر الدببه الراقصه من
اصحابها ووضعوها في محميه خاصه في جبال
ريلا برومانيا بعد ايقاف مهرجان الدببه
الحقيقيه قام المواطنون الرومان من الغجر
بارتداء جلود الدببه ليقوموا بالرقص
بانفسهم على الارض وليس على الصفائح
الساخنه حيث يرتدي الاولاد والرجال ازياء
دب ثقيله وغالبا ما تكون مصنوعه من الفراء
الحقيقي للدببه
[موسيقى]
عن طريق
المهرجان انه حتى الصبيه الصغار يرتدون
فراء دب حقيقي رغم ثقله على اجسادهم قد
يصل وزن فراء الدب الكبير الحجم الى خمسين
كيلو جراما وقد يفوق وزن الصبي نفسه لكن
هنا لا توجد سن محدده للمشاركين الصغار
والكبار والاجداد وكل من يمتلك ثمن الزيت
مدعو للمشاركه
[موسيقى]